now this is to peter market
um it's as you might expect
in the center of
mexico city
teaming with people all the time you can
get anything you'd expect to see in an
ordinary market there's clothes
there's dvds there's food there's
restaurants
so apart from being there's a bustling
place it is also widely regarded as one
of the most dangerous places in the city
this is completely controlled uh by
gangs in fact even while we've been
filming we've stopped countless times of
people refusing to allow their faces to
be seen and checking our pictures
i have jorge with me he's a former world
champion uh boxer uh he knows everyone
here
even his wrist only runs so far once you
have foreigners inside the market
the reason why it is so dangerous
because not only are they selling all
these various goods
it also sells
large amounts of drugs
and large amounts of guns they say here
you can get pretty much anything
hence
without jorge it would be a very very
bad place for us to be